and finally new role before he leaves
office President Obama must send in the
National Guard to desegregate America's
last bastion of societal approved racism
College fraternities that's right
from now on all fraternities must allow
women as well as a diverse collection of
races and ethnicities so you're not
really fraternities anymore you're more
like that hippie co-op on campus where a
house full of art history majors get
stoned every night and makes a big
lentil casserole that's right fellas
gather up your beer funnels and your ass
paddles and your lacrosse sticks and
your big red plastic drinking cups and
get the out
sorry bra now on if you want to live
with 40 other dudes and hold secret
homoerotic ceremonies you're gonna have
to join the seminary
you know it's always struck me as
strange that college campuses are where
political correctness is the most
stringent ly enforced and yet smack in
the middle our frat houses these little
vatican cities of depravity that seemed
to enjoy diplomatic immunity from
civilization
there was a time when fraternities fit
in with society as a whole but that day
is long gone if you don't believe me go
back and watch Animal House in 1978
watching a guy deciding whether he
should have sex with an out cold high
school girl with something we all
considered hilarious and Bill Cosby
still does
Revenge of the Nerds from 1982 has a
scene where they break into a sorority
and install cameras so they can watch
the girls shower and again we all
laughed but this week Penn State's Kappa
Delta Rho frat was caught basically
pulling the same stunt and no one's
laughing
for one thing institutions though that
go out of their way to have no women
around it always leads to abuse and
madness and lighting farts
I mean Scientology is bad the best it
admits women every 10 years someone has
to pretend Mary John Cruz
and there's one other bad little thing
about fraternities they kill people
every year some kid dies when the
hilarious dangled a pledge over the wood
chipper prank goes awry since 1970
there's been at least one hazing related
to debt death every year as pledges
routinely endure alcohol poisoning sleep
deprivation waterboarding being dressed
in diapers buried in trash force-fed cat
food
Jesus why not just pledge Isis well hey
a cult is a cult and that's what a frat
is a place where they strip you of your
personality and rebuild it in their
image that's why when a girl says I'm
dating a frat guy no one ever says oh
yeah what's he like
I just told you I'm dating a friend guy
my school had a lot of fraternities but
it never occurred to me to join one
because finally in my life I was able to
live on my own amongst women so it had
no appeal to me when some frat guy said
hey about coming with me to live with a
bunch of dudes come on come on we'll
stick a carrot up your butt no wonder
they call it the Greek system
and this is where someone always says
but bill fraternities are a tradition
yes I was throwing virgins in a volcano
for a while if you think tradition is a
good enough reason to paint your face or
degrade women or drink yourself sick or
if you think a good place for a bottle
rocket is your ass then maybe college
isn't for you to begin with
of all the bad things fraternities do
the absolute worst is that they take
young people at the exact moment when
they should be learning to be
individuals and turn them into
eating orders following group thinkers
or maybe these guys all independently
decided to wear shorts with a blazer and
a bowtie
you